a lot of interesting stuff both from the
point of view of the content but also
the historical context between you know
when were four loops invented well
that's what Algol called them but prior
to that fortum called them do loops and
prior to that they existed in assembler
so first of all what's the history and
what does it get you when you can do
loops but when do you run out of steam
even with loops and you have to use this
shock horror pure mathematicians thing
that computer scientists have to learn
about recursion it was a real culture
shock it really was in the roughly
nineteen forties 1950s to suddenly find
out that what the Syrians have been
driveling on a mafia is about recursive
functions in mathematics actually was a
massive massive importance for computer
science back in the forties and early
fifties it was all assembler or a
slightly dressed up thing called a macro
assembler where you can have little
routines full of you know packaged
assembler instructions which could be
called up hasn't when needed so that
sort of served people for quite some
time but probably one of the first
high-level languages to introduce lubes
was good old Fortran even though that
was published in 65 Fortran itself goes
like a thing for almost ten years before
that it was invented by John Backus and
a large team of people at IBM in the
1950s many of you will know it it's an
excellent language for engineering and
scientific calculations it is low-level
I mean when you look at the nature of a
Fortran loop it's almost like doing it
in assembler but not quite they didn't
call them for loops form D loops what
I'm saying here is you package all this
up were you're saying
repeat the following sequence of
instructions which I've done with my
wavy lines here keep doing them until
you hit the statement with a numeric
label on it of one a to loop back from
the statement labeled 180 back up to
here to increment the loop counter which
you're all familiar with in languages
other than C it wasn't done as it would
be in C by saying here's my block of
stuff to be repeated it's inside these
curly braces here you can see it's a lot
more like assembler a lot more low-level
I mean nothing magic about 180 it could
be 72 and depended on your labeling
system they implicitly here in a simple
thing like this you'd start off at one
every time I returned back here it would
reset I to be two three four so on up to
an including ten it's comforting for
those who were coming from assembler
into high-level language to see
something that was only slightly higher
level in sophistication than assembler
was how did loops become more powerful
if you like
well again even in assembler and even in
Fortran there's no reason why you
couldn't have a loop within a loop so I
might have outside of all this code yet
another layer of do what should we say
200 J equals 1 comma 20 so there might
be some more statements between 180 and
200 who knows but again you see a
numeric label and can't see what's
happening is that for every setting of J
which will start at 1 and go up to 20
for every single one of those J settings
the inner loop will be running through
the complete spectrum of settings of I
going from 1 to 10 so you will have 200
locations are being affected here
basically going through the rows and
columns of a matrix all sorts of
calculations in physics chemistry and
particularly engineering just rely on
two-dimensional arrays full of numbers
either integers or scientific numbers
were
decimal point and sword even hardcore
assembly pros had to admit if you were
doing heavy scientific program it was
nice to be a little bit more abstract
and to have this sort of facility
available to you now you might say well
what came along to spoil the party then
or how did people realize that this was
wonderful but not quite enough the
compiler of course has got to be
tolerant and has got to be capable of
compiling nested do loops correctly but
what how deep wouldn't let you nest them
well I'm guessing I would suspect that
the early Fortran compilers probably
wouldn't allow you to go more than about
ten deep maximum and I think you and I
surely must be looking up what are the
current limits in C I seem to remember
the earliest GCC was some like 32 but I
think we looked up this some C++
nowadays allows you to do nested loops
256 deep and of course there are
multi-dimensional problems that might
actually need that because it it doesn't
take much knowledge of higher maths to
realize you've got a loop within a loop
the outer loop goes around n times the
inner loop is going around n times you
are then coping with an N squared
problem if you put the third loop inside
the other two you're coping with a cubic
three dimensional problem so what we're
saying is all these multi-dimensional
polynomial going on exponential problems
that come up quite naturally you can
cope with them in nested for-loops so
long as they don't need to be more than
our 30 or power 256 or whatever it is do
you think well that should be enough for
anybody there's these multi-dimensional
problems you can just do them by nesting
for loops and Shirley Turner 56 is
enough for anybody what kind of problem
wouldn't it be enough for well a lot of
theoretical computer scientists of my
knowledge muse me greatly when those of
them that will own up to this back in
the 60s people started going to lectures
from
petitions theoreticians people concerned
with girdle computability and so on and
of course those sort of people were very
familiar indeed at a mathematical level
with a commons function now as you know
you and I we've done that one their most
difficult number to compute question
mark we set this going four weeks ago
nearly now the first few are vanished
off that so what made it so difficult
well you write down atoms function and
it very clearly ends up with routines
calling themselves recursively in a very
very complicated way now I think your
average sort of engineer would be happy
to say that this thing called factorial
which is 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times
1 or whatever and you could do that in a
loop as well as doing this fancy
recursion thing but a lot of
theoreticians admitted to me they saw a
commons function said i could try that
out in fortran now what they perhaps
didn't realize but it became famous by
now these days
fulcrum is wonderful but original
Fortran did not do use a level recursion
you could have right to think all that
you could actually get it to call itself
in Fortran but you might have been
expecting that every time he called
itself it would lay out a data area for
each recursive call they called stack
frames we know that now you get lots of
stack frames one on top of another and
as you come back through the recursion
then deleted and thrown away and you
climb back into your main program
thought Fram doesn't do that it sets
aside one stack frame you keep calling
yourself recursively it just tramples
and it's muddy gumboots over all your
data area and you end it with total
garbage it no more gives you values or a
command function on flight alone
people said yet hope I then realized the
importance of having user level
recursion in programming languages to
cope with those really hard problems
that fell outside nested for-loops
Algol was famous in that it's routines
could call themselves recursively and
could get the right answer and for
limited low order values of a command
function very slow very slow indeed but
it would come out with a right answer
it's so easy to think of example of a
problem or program because that command
feels to me like it's it's like the
testbed you know what yeah yeah a
motor-car you might take it on the track
and see how fast it can go
but in day-to-day life that car might
only get half that speed yeah what's the
real world kind of equivalent is there
such a thing real world equivalent what
kind of thing that might need to use
recursion
there of that complexity not many things
is the answer to that I mean yes it's
true that Ackerman as you know is David
Hilbert's research student and the
challenge was on to find something that
was so innately recursive that remembers
sort of generally recursive they call it
as opposed to primitive recursive and
simple things like factorial and they
need Fibonacci our primitive recursive
so I think you're right that you really
are just making the point that
eventually there are things that will
kill you I think the the question in the
middle is is there something are there
pieces of program you need to write
where non-trivial recursion in a sense
is needed but not quite to the
horrendous degree adamandeve and the
answer is yes compilers is where II hit
people because although early Fortran
did not provide user level recursion for
you and me nevertheless John Backus and
his team implemented it in the middle
1950s I think at I
I am and Bacchus goes after words
basically saying we didn't know enough
about recursion and even though we
didn't provide it for the users of our
language boy did we need it in the
compiler and we invent it
we ended up inventing it in all but name
the syntactic structures of what is
legal in a language even at the level
just of arithmetic statements can be
quite recursive because you end up with
brackets within brackets within brackets
or with a multiplier outside and which
order do you do the brackets in and you
know how how many levels of bracket
nesting can you have and if you don't
get things sorted out correctly then
you'll get their answer but once again
the problem could be that your users
would come up with you and present you
with a problem just designed to test out
your compiler and whether it was robust
enough to be able to cope with a high
degree of nesting even just in
arithmetic statements so by 1960 in
Algol ya the there were enough users at
the user level who could see that a
modicum of recursion perhaps more
complicated than factorial but not quite
up to full ackerman capabilities will be
very nice indeed to have within your
language again referring back to that
original video I had a lot of really
interesting mail from various people who
said to me okay you said that this is an
innately recursive problem and it just
had to have general recursion
capabilities well I